[MUSIC-- "JESU, JOY OF
MAN'S DESIRING" BY
JOHANN SEBASTIAN BACH]
PROFESSOR: Well, there's one bit
of mystery left, which I'd
like to get rid of right now.
And that's that we've been
blithely doing things like
cons assuming there's
always another one.
That we've been doing these
things like car-ing and
cdr-ing and assuming that
we had some idea
how this can be done.
Now indeed we said that that's
equivalent to having
procedures.
But that doesn't really solve
the problem, because the
procedure need all sorts of
complicated mechanisms like
environment structures and
things like that to work.
And those were ultimately made
out of conses in the model
that we had, so that really
doesn't solve the problem.
Now the problem here is
the glue the data
structure's made out of.
What kind of possible
thing could it be?
We've been showing you things
like a machine, a computer
that has a controller, and some
registers, and maybe a stack.
And we haven't said anything
about, for
example, larger memory.
And I think that's what we have
to worry about right now.
But just to make it perfectly
clear that this is an
inessential, purely
implementational thing, I'd
like to show you, for example,
how you can do it
all with the numbers.
That's an easy one.
Famous fellow by the name of
Godel, a logician at the end
of the 1930s, invented a very
clever way of encoding the
complicated expressions
as numbers.
For example--
I'm not saying exactly what
Godel's scheme is, because he
didn't use words like cons.
He had other kinds of ways of
combining to make expressions.
But he said, I'm going to
assign a number to every
algebraic expression.
And the way I'm going to
manufacture these numbers is
by combining the numbers
of the parts.
So for example, what we were
doing our world, we could say
that if objects are represented
by numbers, then
cons of x and y could be
represented by 2 to the x
times 2 to the y.
Because then we could
extract the parts.
We could say, for example, that
then car of, say, x is
the number of factors
of 2 in x.
And of course cdr is
the same thing.
It's the number of factors
of 3 in x.
Now this is a perfectly
reasonable scheme, except for
the fact that the numbers
rapidly get to be much larger
in number of digits
than the number of
protons in the universe.
So there's no easy way to use
this scheme other than the
theoretical one.
On the other hand, there are
other ways of representing
these things.
We have been thinking in
terms of little boxes.
We've been thinking about our
cons structures as looking
sort of like this.
They're little pigeon holes
with things in them.
And of course we arrange
them in little trees.
I wish that the semiconductor
manufacturers would supply me
with something appropriate for
this, but actually what they
do supply me with is
a linear memory.
Memory is sort of a big
pile of pigeonholes,
pigeonholes like this.
Each of which can hold a certain
sized object, a fixed
size object.
So, for example, a complicated
list with 25 elements won't
fit in one of these.
However, each of these is
indexed by an address.
So the address might be zero
here, one here, two here,
three here, and so on.
That we write these down as
numbers is unimportant.
What matters is that they're
distinct as a way to get to
the next one.
And inside of each of these,
we can stuff something into
these pigeonholes.
That's what memory is like, for
those of you who haven't
built a computer.
Now the problem is how are we
going to impose on this type
of structure, this nice
tree structure.
Well it's not very hard, and
there have been numerous
schemes involved in this.
The most important one is to
say, well assuming that the
semiconductor manufacturer
allows me to arrange my memory
so that one of these pigeonholes
is big enough to
hold the address of another
I haven't made.
Now it actually has to be a
little bit bigger because I
have to also install or store
some information as to a tag
which describes the kind
of thing that's there.
And we'll see that
in a second.
And of course if the
semiconductor manufacturer
doesn't arrange it so I can do
that, then of course I can,
with some cleverness, arrange
combinations of these to fit
together in that way.
So we're going to have to
imagine imposing this
complicated tree structure on
our nice linear memory.
If we look at the first still
store, we see a classic scheme
for doing that.
It's a standard way of
representing Lisp structures
in a linear memory.
What we do is we divide this
memory into two parts.
An array called the cars, and
an array called the cdrs.
Now whether those happen to
be sequential addresses or
whatever, it's not important.
That's somebody's implementation
details.
But there are two arrays here.
Linear arrays indexed by
sequential indices like this.
What is stored in each of these
pigeonholes is a typed object.
And what we have here are types
which begin with letters
like p, standing for a pair.
Or n, standing for a number.
Or e, standing for an empty
list. The end of the list. And
so if we wish to represent an
object like this, the list
beginning with 1, 2 and then
having a 3 and a 4 as its
second and third elements.
A list containing a list as its
first part and then two
numbers as a second
and third parts.
Then of course we draw it sort
of like this these days, in
box-and-pointer notation.
And you see, these are the three
cells that have as their
car pointer the object which
is either 1, 2 or 3 or 4.
And then of course the 1, 2,
the car of this entire
structure, is itself a
substructure which contains a
sublist like that.
What I'm about to do is put
down places which are--
I'm going to assign indices.
Like this 1, over here,
represents the
index of this cell.
But that pointer that we see
here is a reference to the
pair of pigeonholes in the cars
and the cdrs that are
labeled by 1 in my linear
memory down here.
So if I wish to impose this
structure on my linear memory,
what I do is I say, oh yes,
why don't we drop
this into cell 1?
I pick one.
There's 1.
And that says that its
car, I'm going to
assign it to be a pair.
It's a pair, which
is in index 5.
And the cdr, which is this one
over here, is a pair which I'm
going to stick into place 2.
p2.
And take a look at p2.
Oh yes, well p2 is a thing whose
car is the number 3, so
as you see, an n3.
And whose cdr, over here, is a
pair, which lives in place 4.
So that's what this p4 is.
p4 is a number whose value is 4
in its car and whose cdr is
an empty list right there.
And that ends it.
So this is the traditional way
of representing this kind of
binary tree in a
linear memory.
Now the next question, of
course, that we might want to
worry about is just a little
bit of implementation.
That means that when I write
procedures of the form
assigned a, [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
procedures--
lines of register machine code
of the form assigned a, the
car of [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
b, what I really mean is
addressing these elements.
And so we're going to think of
that as a abbreviation for it.
Now of course in order to write
that down I'm going to
introduce some sort of a
structure called a vector.
And we're going to have
something which will reference
a vector, just so we
can write it down.
Which takes the name of
the vector, or the--
I don't think that name
is the right word.
Which takes the vector and the
index, and I have to have a
way of setting one of those with
something called a vector
set, I don't really care.
But let's look, for example,
at then that kind of
implementation of car and cdr.
So for example if I happen to
have a register b, which
contains the type index of a
pair, and therefore it is the
pointer to a pair, then I could
take the car of that and
if I-- write this down--
I might put that
in register a.
What that really is is a
representation of the assign
to a, the value of
vector reffing--
or array indexing,
if you will-- or
something, the cars object--
whatever that is--
with the index, b.
And similarly for cdr. And we
can do the same thing for
assignment to data structures,
if we need to do that sort of
thing at all.
It's not too hard
to build that.
Well now the next question
is how are we going to do
allocation.
And every so often I
say I want a cons.
Now conses don't
grow on trees.
Or maybe they should.
But I have to have some way
of getting the next one.
I have to have some idea of if
their memory is unused that I
might want to allocate from.
And there are many schemes
for doing this.
And the particular thing
I'm showing you
right now is not essential.
However it's convenient and
has been done many times.
One scheme's was called the free
list allocation scheme.
What that means is that all of
the free memory that there is
in the world is linked together
in a linked list,
just like all the other stuff.
And whenever you need a free
cell to make a new cons, you
grab the first, one make the
free list be the cdr of it,
and then allocate that.
And so what that looks like
is something like this.
Here we have the free
list starting in 6.
And what that is is a
pointer-off to say 8.
So what it says is, this
one is free and the
next one is an 8.
This one is free and the next
one is in 3, the next one
that's free.
That one's free and the
next one is in 0.
next one's in 15.
Something like that.
We can imagine having
such a structure.
Given that we have something
like that, then it's possible
to just get one when
you need it.
And so a program for doing
cons, this is what
cons might turn into.
To assign to a register A the
result of cons-ing, a B onto
C, the value in this containing
B and the value
containing C, what we have
to do is get the current
[? type ?] ahead of the
freelist, make the free list
be its cdr. Then we have to
change the cars to be the
thing we're making up to be in A
to be the B, the thing in B.
And we have to make change the
cdrs of the thing that's in A
to be C. And then what we have
in A is the right new frob,
whatever it is.
The object that we want.
Now there's a little bit of a
cheat here that I haven't told
you about, which is somewhere
around here I haven't set that
I've the type of the thing that
I'm cons-ing up to be a
pair, and I ought to.
So there should be some sort
of bits here are being set,
and I just haven't written
that down.
We could have arranged it, of
course, for the free lift to
be made out of pairs.
And so then there's no
problem with that.
But that sort of-- again, an
inessential detail in a way
some particular programmer or
architect or whatever might
manufacture his machine
or Lisp system.
So for example, just looking
at this, to allocate given
that I had already the structure
that you saw before,
supposing I wanted to allocate
a new cell, which is going to
be representation of list one,
one, two, where already one
two was the car of the list we
were playing with before.
Well that's not so hard.
I stored that one and one,
so p1 one is the
representation of this.
This is p5.
That's going to be
the cdr of this.
Now we're going to pull
something off the free list,
but remember the free
list started at six.
The new free list after this
allocation is eight, a free
list beginning at eight.
And of course in six now we have
a number one, which is
what we wanted, with its cdr
being the pair starting in
location five.
And that's no big deal.
So the only problem really
remaining here is, well, I
don't have an infinitely
large memory.
If I do this for a little
while, say, for example,
supposing it takes me a
microsecond to do a cons, and
I have a million cons memory
then I'm only going to run out
in a second, and that's
pretty bad.
So what we do to prevent that
disaster, that ecological
disaster, talk about right
after questions.
Are there any questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: In the environment
diagrams that we were drawing
we would use the body of
procedures, and you would
eventually wind up with things
that were no longer useful in
that structure.
How is that represented?
PROFESSOR: There's two
problems here.
One you were asking is that
material becomes useless.
We'll talk about that
in a second.
That has to do with how to
prevent ecological disasters.
If I make a lot of garbage I
have to somehow be able to
clean up after myself.
And we'll talk about
that in a second.
The other question you're asking
is how you represent
the environments, I think.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: OK.
And the environment structures
can be represented in
arbitrary ways.
There are lots of them.
I mean, here I'm just telling
you about list cells.
Of course every real system
has vectors of arbitrary
length as well as the vectors
of length, too, which
represent list cells.
And the environment structures
that one uses in a
professionally written Lisp
system tend to be vectors
which contain a number of
elements approximately equal
to the number of arguments-- a
little bit more because you
need certain glue.
So remember, the environment
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
frames.
The frames are constructed
by applying a procedure.
In doing so, an allocation is
made of a place which is the
number of arguments long
plus [? unglue ?]
that gets linked into a chain.
It's just like algol
at that level.
There any other questions?
OK.
Thank you, and let's
take a short break.
[MUSIC-- "JESU, JOY OF
MAN'S DESIRING" BY
JOHANN SEBASTIAN BACH]
PROFESSOR: Well, as I just
said, computer memories
supplied by the semiconductor
manufacturers are finite.
And that's quite a pity.
It might not always
be that way.
Just for a quick calculation,
you can see that it's possible
that if [? memory ?]
prices keep going at the rate
they're going that if you
still took a microsecond second
to do a cons, then--
first of all, everybody should
know that there's about pi
times ten to the seventh
seconds in a year.
And so that would be ten to the
seventh plus ten to the
sixth is ten to the
thirteenth.
So there's maybe ten to the
fourteenth conses in the life
of a machine.
If there was ten to the
fourteenth words of memory on
your machine, you'd
never run out.
And that's not completely
unreasonable.
Ten to the fourteenth is not
a very large number.
I don't think it is.
But then again I like to
play with astronomy.
It's at least ten to the
eighteenth centimeters between
us and the nearest star.
But the thing I'm about to worry
about is, at least in
the current economic state of
affairs, ten to the fourteenth
pieces of memory is expensive.
And so I suppose what we
have to do is make
do with much smaller.
Memories
Now in general we want to have
an illusion of infinity.
All we need to do is arrange it
so that whenever you look,
the thing is there.
That's really an
important idea.
A person or a computer lives
only a finite amount of time
and can only take a finite
number of looks at something.
And so you really only need
a finite amount of stuff.
But you have to arrange it so
no matter how much there is,
how much you really claim
there is, there's always
enough stuff so that when you
take a look, it's there.
And so you only need
a finite amount.
But let's see.
One problem is, as was brought
up, that there are possible
ways that there is lots of stuff
that we make that we
don't need.
And we could recycle
the material out
of which its made.
An example is the fact that
we're building environment
structures, and we do so every
time we call a procedure.
We have built in it a
environment frame.
That environment frame
doesn't necessarily
have a very long lifetime.
Its lifetime, meaning its
usefulness, may exist only
over the invocation
of the procedure.
Or if the procedure exports
another procedure by returning
it as a value and that procedure
is defined inside of
it, well then the lifetime
of the frame of the outer
procedure still is only the
lifetime of the procedure
which was exported.
And so ultimately, a lot
of that is garbage.
There are other ways of
producing garbage as well.
Users produce garbage.
An example of user garbage
is something like this.
If we write a program to, for
example, append two lists
together, well one way to do
it is to reverse the first
list onto the empty list and
reverse that onto the second
list. Now that's not terribly
bad way of doing it.
And however, the intermediate
result, which is the reversal
of the first list as done by
this program, is never going
to be accessed ever again after
it's copied back on to
the second.
It's an intermediate result.
It's going to be hard to ever
see how anybody would ever be
able to access it.
In fact, it will go away.
Now if we make a lot of garbage
like that, and we
should be allowed to, then
there's got to be some way to
reclaim that garbage.
Well, what I'd like to tell you
about now is a very clever
technique whereby a Lisp system
can prove a small
theorem every so often on the
[? forum, ?] the following
piece of junk will never
be accessed again.
It can have no affect on the
future of the computation.
It's actually based on
a very simple idea.
We've designed our computers
to look sort of like this.
There's some data path, which
contains the registers.
There are things like x, and
env, and val, and so on.
And there's one here called
stack, some sort which points
off to a structure somewhere,
which is the stack.
And we'll worry about
that in a second.
There's some finite controller,
finite state
machine controller.
And there's some control signals
that go this way and
predicate results that
come this way, not
the interesting part.
There's some sort of structured
memory, which I
just told you how to make, which
may contain a stack.
I didn't tell you how to make
things of arbitrary shape,
only pairs.
But in fact with what I've told
you can simulate a stack
by a big list. I don't plan
to do that, it's not a
nice way to do it.
But we could have something
like that.
We have all sorts of little data
structures in here that
are hooked together
in funny ways.
They connect to other things.
And so on.
And ultimately things up there
are pointers to these.
The things that are in the
registers are pointers off to
the data structures that live in
this Lisp structure memory.
Now the truth of the matter is
that the entire consciousness
of this machine is in
these registers.
There is no possible way that
the machine, if done
correctly, if built correctly,
can access anything in this
Lisp structure memory unless
the thing in that Lisp
structure memory is connected
by a sequence of data
structures to the registers.
If it's accessible by legitimate
data structure
selectors from the
pointers that are
stored in these registers.
Things like array references,
perhaps.
Or cons cell references,
cars and cdrs.
But I can't just talk about a
random place in this memory,
because I can't get to it.
These are being arbitrary
names I'm not allowed to
count, at least as I'm
evaluating expressions.
If that's the case then there's
a very simple theorem
to be proved.
Which is, if I start with all
lead pointers that are in all
these registers and recursively
chase out, marking
all the places I can get to by
selectors, then eventually I
mark everything they
can be gotten to.
Anything which is
not so marked is
garbage and can be recycled.
Very simple.
Cannot affect the future
of the computation.
So let me show you that in
a particular example.
Now that means I'm going
to have to append to my
description of the list
structure a mark.
And so here, for example, is
a Lisp structured memory.
And in this Lisp structured
memory is a Lisp structure
beginning in a place
I'm going to call--
this is the root.
Now it doesn't really
have to have a root.
It could be a bunch of them,
like all the registers.
But I could cleverly arrange it
so all the registers, all
the things that are in old
registers are also at the
right moment put into this root
structure, and then we've
got one pointer to it.
I don't really care.
So the idea is we're going to
cons up stuff until our free
list is empty.
We've run out of things.
Now we're going to do this
process of proving the theorem
that a certain percentage of the
memory has got crap in it.
And then we're going to recycle
that to grow new
trees, a standard use
of such garbage.
So in any case, what
do we have here?
Well we have some data structure
which starts out
over here one.
And in fact it has a car in
five, and its cdr is in two.
And all the marks start
out at zero.
Well let's start marking,
just to play this game.
OK.
So for example, since I can
access one from the root I
will mark that.
Let me mark it.
Bang.
That's marked.
Now since I have a five here I
can go to five and see, well
I'll mark that.
Bang.
That's useful stuff.
But five references as a number
in its car, I'm not
interested in marking numbers
but its cdr is seven.
So I can mark that.
Bang.
Seven is the empty list, the
only thing that references,
and it's got a number
in its car.
Not interesting.
Well now let's go back here.
I forgot about something.
Two.
See in other words, if I'm
looking at cell one, cell one
contains a two right
over here.
A reference to two.
That means I should
go mark two.
Bang.
Two contains a reference
to four.
It's got a number in its car,
I'm not interested in that, so
I'm going to go mark that.
Four refers to seven through its
car, and is empty in its
cdr, but I've already marked
that one so I don't have to
mark it again.
This is all the accessible
structure from that place.
Simple recursive
mark algorithm.
Now there are some unhappinesses
about that
algorithm, and we can worry
about that a second.
But basically you'll see that
all the things that have not
been marked are places that are
free, and I could recycle.
So the next stage after that is
going to be to scan through
all of my memory, looking for
things that are not marked.
Every time I come across a
marked thing I unmark it, and
every time I come across an
unmarked thing I'm going to
link it together in
my free list.
Classic, very simple algorithm.
So let's see.
Is that very simple?
Yes it is.
I'm not going to go through the
code in any detail, but I
just want to show you about
how long it is.
Let's look at the mark phase.
Here's the first part
of the mark phase.
We pick up the root.
We're going to use that as a
recursive procedure call.
We're going to sweep from there,
after when we're done
with marking.
And then we're going to do a
little couple of instructions
that do this checking out on
the marks and changing the
marks and things like that,
according to the algorithm
I've just shown you.
It comes out here.
You have to mark the cars of
things and you also have to be
able to mark the
cdrs of things.
That's the entire mark phase.
I'll just tell you a little
story about this.
The old DEC PDP-6 computer,
this was the way that the
mark-sweep garbage collection,
as it was, was written.
The program was so small that
with the data that it needed,
with the registers that it
needed to manipulate the
memory, it fit into the fast
registers of the machine,
which were 16.
The whole program.
And you could execute
instructions in the fast registers.
So it's an extremely small
program, and it could run very
fast.
Now unfortunately, of course,
this program, because the fact
that it's recursive in the way
that you do something first
and then you do something after
that, you have to work
on the cars and then the cdrs,
it requires auxiliary memory.
So Lisp systems--
those requires a stack
for marking.
Lisp systems that are built this
way have a limit to the
depth of recursion you can have
in data structures in
either the car or the cdr, and
that doesn't work very nicely.
On the other hand, you never
notice it if it's big enough.
And that's certainly been the
case for most Maclisp, for
example, which ran Macsyma
where you could deal with
expressions of thousands
of elements long.
These are algebraic expressions
with thousand of
terms. And there's no
problem with that.
Such, the garbage collector
does work.
On the other hand, there's a
very clever modification to
this algorithm, which I will not
describe, by Peter Deutsch
and Schorr and Waite--
Herb Schorr from IBM and Waite,
who I don't know.
That algorithm allows you to
build-- you do can do this
without auxiliary memory, by
remembering as you walk the
data structures where you came
from by reversing the pointers
as you go down and crawling
up the reverse
pointers as you go up.
It's a rather tricky
algorithm.
The first time you write it--
or in fact, the first three
times you write it it has
a terrible bug in it.
And it's also rather slow,
because it's complicated.
It takes about six times as many
memory references to do
the sorts of things that
we're talking about.
Well now once I've done this
marking phase, and I get into
a position where things look
like this, let's look--
yes.
Here we have the mark done,
just as I did it.
Now we have to perform
the sweep phase.
And I described to you what
this sweep is like.
I'm going to walk down from
one end of memory or the
other, I don't care where,
scanning every cell that's in
the memory.
And as I scan these cells, I'm
going to link them together,
if they are free, into the free
list. And if they're not
free, I'm going to unmark them
so the marks become zero.
And in fact what I get-- well
the program is not very
complicated.
It looks sort of like this--
it's a little longer.
Here's the first piece of it.
This one's coming down from
the top of memory.
I don't want you to try to
understand this at this point.
It's rather simple.
It's a very simple algorithm,
but there's pieces of it that
just sort of look like this.
They're all sort of obvious.
And after we've done the sweep,
we get an answer that
looks like that.
Now there are some disadvantages
with mark-sweep
algorithms of this sort.
Serious ones.
One important disadvantage is
that your memories get larger
and larger.
As you say, address spaces get
larger and larger, you're
willing to represent more and
more stuff, then it gets very
costly to scan all of memory.
What you'd really like to do
is only scan useful stuff.
It would even be better if you
realized that some stuff was
known to be good and useful, and
you don't have to look at
it more than once or twice.
Or very rarely.
Whereas other stuff that you're
not so sure about, you
can look at more detail every
time you want to do this, want
to garbage collect.
Well there are algorithms that
are organized in this way.
Let me tell you about a famous
old algorithm which allows you
only look at the part
of memory which
is known to be useful.
And which happens to be the
fastest known garbage
collector algorithm.
This is the
Minsky-Feinchel-Yochelson
garbage collector algorithm.
It was invented by Minsky in
1961 or '60 or something, for
the RLE PDP-1 Lisp, which had
4,096 words of list memory,
and a drum.
And the whole idea was
to garbage collect
this terrible memory.
What Minsky realized was the
easiest way to do this is to
scan the memory in the same
sense, walking the good
structure, copying it out into
the drum, compacted.
And then when we were done
copying it all out, then you
swap that back into
your memory.
Now whether or you not use a
drum, or another piece of
memory, or something like
that isn't important.
In fact, I don't think
people use
drums anymore for anything.
But this algorithm basically
depends upon having about
twice as much address space
as you're actually using.
And so what you have is some,
initially, some mixture of
useful data and garbage.
So this is called fromspace.
And this is a mixture of crud.
Some of it's important
and some of it isn't.
Now there's another place which
is hopefully big enough,
if we recall, tospace, which
is where we're copying to.
And what happens is-- and
I'm not going to go
through this detail.
It's in our book quite
explicitly.
There's a root point where
you start from.
And the idea is that you
start with the root.
You copy the first thing you
see, the first thing that the
root points at, to the
beginning of tospace.
The first thing is a
pair or something
like, a data structure.
You then also leave behind a
broken heart saying, I moved
this object from here to
here, giving the place
where it moved to.
This is called a broken heart
because a friend of mine who
implemented one of these in
1966 was a very romantic
character and called
it a broken heart.
But in any case, the next thing
you do is now you have a
new free pointer which is here,
and you start scanning.
You scan this data structure
you just copied.
And every time you encounter a
pointer in it, you treat it as
if it was the root
pointer here.
Oh, I'm sorry.
The other thing you do
is you now move the
root pointer to there.
So now you scan this, and
everything you see you treat
as it were the root pointer.
So if you see something,
well it points
up into there somewhere.
Is it pointing at a thing which
you've not copied yet?
Is there a broken heart there?
If there's a broken heart there
and it's something you
have copied, you've just
replaced this pointer with the
thing a broken heart
points at.
If this thing has not been
copied, you copy it to the
next place over here.
Move your free pointer over
here, and then leave a broken
heart behind and scan.
And eventually when the scant
pointer hits the free pointer,
everything in memory
has been copied.
And then there's a whole bunch
of empty space up here, which
you could either make into a
free list, if that's what you
want to do.
But generally you don't in
this kind of system.
In this system you sequentially
allocate your memory.
That is a very, very nice
algorithm, and sort of the one
we use in the scheme that
you've been using.
And it's expected--
I believe no one has found a
faster algorithm than that.
There are very simple
modifications to this
algorithm invented by Henry
Baker which allow one to run
this algorithm in real time,
meaning you don't have to stop
to garbage collect.
But you could interleave the
consing that the machine does
when its running with steps
of the garbage collection
process, so that the garbage
collector's distributed, and
the machine doesn't have
to stop, and garbage
collecting can start.
Of course in the case of
machines with virtual memory
where a lot of it is in
inaccessible places, this
becomes a very expensive
process.
And there have been numerous
attempts to
make this much better.
There is a nice paper, for
those of you who are
interested, by Moon and other
people which describes a
modification to the
incremental
Minsky-Feinchel-Yochelson
algorithm, and modification
the Baker algorithm which is
more efficient for virtual
memory systems.
Well I think now the mystery
to this is sort of gone.
And I'd like to see if there
are any questions.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I saw one of you run
the garbage collector on the
systems upstairs, and it seemed
to me to run extremely
fast. Did the whole
thing take--
does it sweep through
all of memory?
PROFESSOR: No.
It swept through exactly
what was needed to
copy the useful structure.
It's a copying collector.
And it is very fast. On the
whole, I suppose to copy--
in a Bobcat--
to copy, I think, a three
megabyte thing or something is
less than a second, real time.
Really, these are very small
programs. One thing you should
realise is that garbage
collectors have to be small.
Not because they have to be
fast, but because no one can
debug a complicated
garbage collector.
A garbage collector, if it
doesn't work, will trash your
memory in such a way that you
cannot figure out what the
hell happened.
You need an audit trail.
Because it rearranges
everything, and how do you
know what happened there?
So this is the only kind of
program that it really,
seriously matters if you stare
at it long enough so you
believe that it works.
And sort of prove
it to yourself.
So there's no way to debug it.
And that takes it being small
enough so you can
hold it in your head.
Garbage collectors are
special in this way.
So every reasonable garbage
collector has gotten small,
and generally small programs
are fast. Yes.
AUDIENCE: Can you repeat
the name of this
technique once again?
PROFESSOR: That's the
Minsky-Feinchel-Yochelson
garbage collector.
AUDIENCE: You got that?
PROFESSOR: Minsky invented it
in '61 for the RLE PDP-1.
A version of it was developed
and elaborated to be used in
Multics Maclisp by Feinchel
and Yochelson in somewhere
around 1968 or '69.
OK.
Let's take a break.
[MUSIC: "JESU, JOY OF
MAN'S DESIRING" BY
JOHANN SEBASTIAN BACH]
PROFESSOR: Well we've come to
the end of this subject, and
we've already shown you a
universal machine which is
down to evaluator.
It's down to the level of detail
you could imagine you
could make one.
This is a particular
implementation of Lisp, built
on one of those scheme chips
that was talked about
yesterday, sitting over here.
This is mostly interface to
somebody's memory with a
little bit of timing and
other such stuff.
But this fellow actually ran
Lisp at a fairly reasonable
rate, as interpretive.
It ran Lisp as fast as a DEC
PDP-10 back in 1979.
And so it's gotten
pretty hardware.
Pretty concrete.
We've also downed you
a bit with the
things you can compute.
But is it the case that there
are things we can't compute?
And so I'd like to end this with
showing you some things
that you'd like be able to
compute that you can't.
The answer is yes, there are
things you can't compute.
For example, something you'd
really like is--
if you're writing
[UNINTELLIGIBLE], you'd like a
program that would check
that the thing you're
going to do will work.
Wouldn't that be nice?
You'd like something that would
catch infinite loops,
for example, in programs that
were written by users.
But in general you can't write
such a program that will read
any program and determine
whether or not it's an
infinite loop.
Let me show you that.
It's a little bit of a
minor mathematics.
Let's imagine that we just
had a mathematical
function before we start.
And there is one, called s,
which takes a procedure and
its argument, a.
And what s does is it determines
whether or not it's
safe to run p on a.
And what I mean by that is this:
it's true if p applied
to a will converge to a value
without an error.
And it's false if p of a loops
forever or makes an error.
Now that's surely a function.
There is some for every
procedure and for every
argument you could give it that
is either true or false
that it converges without
making an error.
And you could make a giant
table of them.
But the question is, can you
write a procedure that compute
the values of this function?
Well let's assume that we can.
Suppose that we have a procedure
called "safe" that
computes the value of s.
Now I'm going to show you
by several methods that
you can't do this.
The easiest one, or the first
one, let's define a procedure
called diag1.
Given that we have safe, we
can define diag1 to be the
procedure of one argument, p,
which has the following
properties.
If if it's safe to apply p to
itself, then I wish to have an
infinite loop.
Otherwise I'm going
to return 3.
Remember it was 42.
What's the answer to
the big question?
Where of course we know what
an infinite loop is.
Infinite loop, to be a procedure
of no arguments,
which is that nice lambda
calculus loop.
Lambda of x, x of x, applied
to lambda of x, x of x.
So there's nothing left to
the imagination here.
Well let's see what
the story is.
I'm supposing it's the case
that we worry about the
procedure called diag1
applied to diag1.
Well what could it
possibly be?
Well I don't know.
We're going to substitute diag1
for p in the body here.
Well is it safe to compute
diag1 of diag1?
I don't know.
There are two possibilities.
If it's safe to compute diag1
of diag1 that means it
shouldn't loop.
That means I go to
here, but then I
produce an infinite loop.
So it can't be safe.
But if it's not safe to compute
diag1 of diag1 then
the answer to this is 3.
But that's diag1 of diag1,
so it had to be safe.
So therefore by contradiction
you cannot produce safe.
For those of you who were
boggled by that one I'm going
to say it again, in
a different way.
Listen to one more
alternative.
Let's define diag2.
These are named diag because of
Cantor's diagonal argument.
These are instances of a famous
argument which was
originally used by Cantor in
the late part of the last
century to prove that the real
numbers were not countable,
that there are too many
real numbers to
be counted by integers.
That there are more points on
a line, for example, than
there are counting numbers.
It may or may not be obvious,
and I don't want to
get into that now.
But diag2 is again a procedure
of one argument p.
It's almost the same as the
previous one, which is, if
it's safe to compute p on p,
then I'm going to produce--
then I want to compute
some other things
other than p of p.
Otherwise I'm going
to put out false.
Where other then it says,
whatever p of p, I'm going to
put out something else.
I can give you an example of a
definition of other than which
I think works.
Let's see.
Yes.
Where other than be a procedure
of one argument x
which says, if its eq x to, say,
quote a, then the answer
is quote b.
Otherwise it's quote a.
That always produces something
which is not what
its argument is.
That's all it is.
That's all I wanted.
Well now let's consider this
one, diag2 of diag2.
Well look.
This only does something
dangerous, like calling p of
p, if it's safe to do so.
So if safe defined at all,
if you can define such a
procedure, safe, then this
procedure is always defined
and therefore safe
on any inputs.
So diag2 of diag2 must reduce to
other than diag2 of diag2.
And that doesn't make sense,
so we have a contradiction,
and therefore we can't
define safe.
I just waned to do that twice,
slightly differently, so you
wouldn't feel that the first
one was a trick.
They may be both tricks,
but they're at
least slightly different.
So I suppose that pretty
much wraps it up.
I've just proved what we call
the halting theorem, and I
suppose with that we're
going to halt.
I hope you have a good time.
Are there any questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: What is the
value of s of diag1?
PROFESSOR: Of what?
AUDIENCE: S of diag1.
If you said s is a function
and we can
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: Oh, I don't know.
I don't know.
It's a function, but I don't
know how to compute it.
I can't do it.
I'm just a machine, too.
Right?
There's no machine that
in principle--
it might be that in that
particular case you just
asked, with some thinking
I could figure it out.
But in general I can't compute
the value of s any better than
any other machine can.
There is such a function, it's
just that no machine can be
built to compute it.
Now there's a way of saying
that that should not be
surprising.
Going through this--
I mean, I don't have time to do
this here, but the number
of functions is very large.
If there's a certain number of
answers possible and a certain
number of inputs possible,
then it's the number of
answers raised to the number
inputs is the number of
possible functions.
On one variable.
Now that's always bigger than
the thing you're raising to,
the exponent.
The number of functions is
larger than the number of
programs that one
can write, by an
infinity counting argument.
And it's much larger.
So there must be a lot of
functions that can't be
computed by programs.
AUDIENCE: A few moments ago
you were talking about
specifications and automatic
generation of solutions.
Do you see any steps between
specifications and solutions?
PROFESSOR: Steps between.
You mean, you're saying, how
you go about constructing
devices given that have
specifications for the device?
Sure.
AUDIENCE: There's a lot of
software engineering that goes
through specifications through
many layers of design and then
implementation.
PROFESSOR: Yes?
AUDIENCE: I was curious if you
think that's realistic.
PROFESSOR: Well I think that
some of it's realistic and
some of it isn't.
I mean, surely if I want to
build an electrical filter and
I have a rather interesting
possibility.
Supposing I want to build a
thing that matches some power
output to the radio transmitter,
to some antenna.
And I'm really out
of this power--
it's output tube out here.
And the problem is that they
have different impedances.
I want them to match
the impedances.
I also want to make a filter in
there which is going to get
rid of some harmonic
radiation.
Well one old-fashioned technique
for doing this is
called image impedances,
or something like that.
And what you do is you
say you have a basic
module called an L-section.
Looks like this.
If I happen to connect this to
some resistance, r, and if I
make this impedance x, xl, and
if it happens to be q times r,
then this produces a low pass
filter with a q square plus
one impedance match.
Just what I need.
Because now I can take two
of these, hook them
together like this.
OK, and I take another one
and I'll hook them
together like that.
And I have two L-sections
hooked together.
And this will step the impedance
down to one that I
know, and this will step
it up to one I know.
Each of these is a
low pass filter
getting rid of some harmonics.
It's good filter, it's called
a pie-section filter.
Great.
Except for the fact that in
doing what I just did, I've
made a terrible inefficiency
in this system.
I've made two coils where
I should have made one.
And the problem with most
software engineering art is
that there's no mechanism,
other than peephole
optimization and compilers,
for getting rid of the
redundant parts that are
constructed when doing top
down design.
It's even worse, there are
lots of very important
structures that you can't
construct at all this way.
So I think that the standard
top down design is a rather
shallow business.
Doesn't really capture what
people want to do in design.
I'll give you another
electrical example.
Electrical examples are
so much clearer than
computational examples, because
computation examples
require a certain degree of
complexity to explain them.
But one of my favorite examples
in the electrical
world is how would I ever come
up with the output stage of
this inter-stage connection
in an IF amplifier.
It's a little transistor
here, and let's see.
Well I'm going to have a tank,
and I'm going to hook this up
to, say, I'm going to
link-couple that to the input
of the next stage.
Here's a perfectly
plausible plan--
well except for the fact that
since I put that going up I
should make that
going that way.
Here's a perfectly plausible
plan for a--
no I shouldn't.
I'm dumb.
Excuse me.
Doesn't matter.
The point is [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
plan for a couple
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
stages together.
Now what the problem is is
what's this hierarchically?
It's not one thing.
Hierarchically it doesn't
make any sense at all.
It's the inductance of a tuned
circuit, it's the primary of a
transformer, and it's also
the DC path by which bias
conditions get to the collector
of that transistor.
And there's no simple top-down
design that's going to produce
a structure like that with so
many overlapping uses for a
particular thing.
Playing Scrabble, where you have
to do triple word scores,
or whatever, is not so easy in
top-down design strategy.
Yet most of real engineering is
based on getting the most
oomph for effort.
And that's what you're
seeing here.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is this the
last question?
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: Apparently so.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC-- "JESU, JOY OF
MAN'S DESIRING" BY
JOHANN SEBASTIAN BACH]